feels great you know I'm excited
um you know there's a lot to play for a
lot on the line hopefully I do well
fingers crossed yeah I'm very excited to
be in this tournament this as well as in
the previous US junior tournaments and
St Louis chess club tournaments and I
hope to like get a better performance
and
previous times I I've played I played
here so yeah I I hope I can play some
very interesting games it feels great
coming back to the world's best chess
club and yeah if I'm top seed I hope to
win this and get an invite to us
Championship which is of course the main
reason of coming here
um of course I'm very excited and very
honored to play against all these very
strong players it's a great opportunity
I'm very excited to play with all these
top Juniors I'm extremely grateful to be
invited I only knew that I was going to
be invited like the last week so I'm
definitely excited to perform well at
this tournament as always it feels
really nice St Louis chess club has only
had good memories for me no matter how
the tournament is the tournament's
always nice it has very strong fields
and nice conditions so never any
complaints um I'm just super excited um
personally you know if I didn't get an
invite for this tournament I don't know
what I'd be doing probably playing
basketball so
um just excited to be on in one of the
best chess clubs in the world I mean it
feels great you know at the start of
year I was definitely not expecting to
to get invited to determine and I had a
good series of events and was able to
secure the wild card so I'm honestly
just thrilled to play oh it's a dream
come true I mean this is my first time
here I've watched all these um other
Idols of Mine played for so many years
I've always been watching a broadcast so
if you ask her and everybody so it's a
very nice experience you know it feels
amazing this is my last year so I'm
feeling old now you know all the people
I grew up with about aged out of the
tournament but it's gonna be fun you
know just trying to have fun with it
it's my last year here in the past past
I put a lot of pressure in myself to
perform well but at this point I think I
don't really have that many expectations
um so yeah it's amazing to be back as
always and just hopefully trying to
enjoy my last year here
foreign